i'm gonna start with something a little
bit different today i think this is
important i think this is a good way to
get some insight into some of the
really like the worst talking points and
and the worst propaganda right now being
spread by some on the right
uh i i think disappointment something
really disappointing happened on tuesday
on the joe rogan podcast
uh dan crenshaw took joe rogan for a
ride i don't know how else to say it dan
crenshaw is a republican congressman
and he is increasingly in favor with
trumpists he came to prominence uh
sort of fell into favor with donald
trump when he defended donald trump's
handling of coronavirus which is
i mean i can't imagine a bigger failure
for
trump than coronavirus a global
embarrassment and dan crenshaw
came to the forefront saying look at how
great of a job actually donald trump has
done on this issue and sadly joe rogan
got taken for a ride
by dan crenshaw's slick but wrong
claims about all sorts of different
things
and the the reason i'm saying that
crenshaw takes joe rogan for a ride
is that it seems pretty clear that dan
crenshaw knows that he's bs'ing
dan crenshaw knows that when he tells
these lies these are lies he's not
ignorant
he is smart enough to know that he's
saying
untrue things and some of them he gets
past joe rogan some of them
joe's kind of bs meter goes off and he
says hold on a second is that does that
make sense or doesn't it make sense but
there's this sort of
cult of personality that's developed
around dan crenshaw
as if he's some epic truth-teller of
conservative truths that are irrefutable
but really dan crenshaw it's sort of ben
shapiro like with a lower pitched voice
he
says things that are wrong lower pitched
voice and slower speaking cadence
dan crenshaw like ben shapiro says
things that are wrong
but says them confidently and oftentimes
people don't challenge him so
let's jump in a thanks to scott one of
our viewers for sending me some of the
notable moments from this interview
here is one moment on the topic of
medicaid
to his credit joe rogan's bs meter does
go off here but crenshaw's
mildly prepared so let's take a look at
it and then discuss
yeah so instead of spending all this
money on on medicaid for instance
okay take the people who are eligible
for medicaid and even above that right
and you could you could have a
tiered program instead of wasting all
that money on a medicaid program that
doesn't have
uh improved outcomes by the way every
study shows this
what do you mean by that it doesn't have
improvement it means that when you
compare people from the same
socioeconomic status
and they're in medicaid enrolled or they
have no insurance at all their health
outcomes are no
different so is that malarkey is that
[ __ ] around with statistics a lot
a lot a lot of studies have shown this
but hold on you're talking about someone
getting
medical care or not getting no no they
still because you always get medical
care
okay so the claim is if you're going to
do this
you first have to be really clear as to
what the claim
that's being made is the claim being
made by dan crenshaw
is that people with medicaid do no
better in terms of health outcomes than
people with no
insurance assuming they're of the same
socioeconomic status
so two people who earn twenty two
thousand dollars a year
one has medicaid one has no insurance
dan crenshaw says
they have the exact same health outcomes
because as he says people with no
insurance
can still get care by going to the
emergency room
uh and not paying their bill or by going
to a doctor
and not paying their bill or whatever so
so medicaid really does nothing but it
costs money
medicaid is bad in that sense dan
crenshaw cites
that there's lots of studies that say
this
research this and you will very quickly
figure out where this comes from
this claim that people do no better
on medicaid than without insurance
given the same socioeconomic level all
goes back to one
study called the oregon health insurance
experiment
this is from 2013. this is like this
this is this is meat right you need to
understand this stuff to understand
these talking points they come up with
this is a 2013 study
and it looked in oregon and said what
happened when oregon did the obamacare
medicaid expansion
and a bunch of people who previously
didn't have health insurance got
medicaid
and then we followed some of that people
now
some of those people it's true the study
claims
that quote this randomized controlled
study
showed medicaid coverage generated no
significant
improvements in physical health outcomes
in the first two years
but it did increase use of health care
services
raised rates of detecting diabetes and
managing diabetes
lowered rates of depression and reduced
financial strain so
let's analyze each finding individually
the main
important one that is at issue with dan
crenshaw is
the people who got the medicaid coverage
generated
no significant improvement in measured
health outcomes in the first two years
but when you look at the details you
very quickly realize that this is an
almost meaningless claim how did they
measure health
outcomes they looked only at three
factors
and only for two years the three factors
that were used were
blood pressure cholesterol and what's
called
glycated hemoglobin level levels which
measure
diabetic blood sugar and they tracked
just those three indicators for two
years
now i hope that it's becoming clear how
slippery that is
any other improvements eliminating pain
treating infections sooner lowering bmi
none of that is there all they looked at
is blood pressure
cholesterol and glycated hemoglobin
levels
these aren't even close to the most
common reasons people go to doctors
the most common reasons that people go
to doctors
are skin issues of various kinds
joint pain and arthritis pain back pain
respiratory issues including colds that
start to affect
respiration flu bronchitis pneumonia
copd emphysema
anxiety and depression neurological
issues
headaches and migraines and yes you also
have on that top 12 list
towards the bottom cholesterol and blood
pressure so
the study that dan crenshaw is talking
about
he may not even know what his talking
point uh that his talking point is
actually based on the study
it didn't measure anything about changes
or outcomes related to 10 of the top 12
reasons people go to the doctor
it's it's meaningless in this context
and by the way
it only looked at two years many of
these things unfortunately take longer
for people to
successfully treat and improve upon um
so when he says
the people on medicaid don't do any
better measured
only by looking at cholesterol blood
pressure and diabetic blood sugar
doesn't make sense very incomplete and
and by the way the study
also found that when people got medicaid
after not having it
and you compare the two groups they were
detecting that they were diabetic or
pre-diabetic they were managing that at
a higher rate
depression rates went down and financial
strain went went down which is a good
thing so it's a complete and total
gaslight
dan crenshaw is spouting something that
is almost completely meaningless it's
wrong it's the opposite
of the truth and crenshaw is really
pernicious
specifically because he sounds so normal
and calm and confident and knowledgeable
when he says things that are totally
wrong
compared to for example like when you
hear madison cawthorne speak
he doesn't inspire confidence when you
hear madison uh
marjorie taylor green or lauren beaubert
not only are they saying things that are
wrong
they sound totally not credible when dan
crenshaw says things that are wrong he
actually sounds credible
let's look at another example and this
was something that came out
like whenever someone says i want to
make a list of people like hey hey hey
hey hey it's a little like fascism yeah
this is
you're getting dangerous here this is a
weird thing you're doing
because the biggest lie of of this
century
is that there's this like american
right-wing fascism
the the the only fascism i see is well i
mean those blatant example is the antifa
crazies who who deliberately engage in
fascist tactics to to implement their
little
form of utopia um but also like what
we're talking about in georgia all these
corporations engaging what they're
engaging and this is fascism
this forced conformity yes like and
fascism
there's lots of kind of definitions look
at dan
crenshaw claim that everybody else
is misstating what fascism is that some
say fascism is only hitler and he'll
tell you
what the real fascism is and he says
corporations expressing an opinion about
a law they don't like is fascism
when coca-cola criticizes the georgia
voting law or says we're not going to do
mlb says we're not going to do business
with georgia dan crenshaw wants you to
believe that that's fascism and
he liked this talking point so much that
he used it last night on fox news as
well
we won't we won't go to that dan
crenshaw much like donald trump used to
say
wants you to believe everybody else is
lying to you about what things are i
will tell you the truth but then he lies
to you
he says all of these other people are
saying that
this is fascism that's fashion no no the
real fashion fascism is antifa
which is an anti-fascist group and
corporations criticizing georgia
that's fascism fascism is when a system
of government
or a movement or a regime puts nation
and sometimes race above the individual
and has
centralized autocratic authoritarian
government
often headed by a dictator with severe
economic and social regimentation and
forcible suppression of the opposition
when a for-profit corporation is free to
say we don't like this law
we might leave georgia and citizens are
free to say oh i like that idea i'm
going to support
coca-cola for example or i don't like
what coke is doing i'm not going to
support them
i'm going to boycott them that's not
fascism that's free market economy
that's it
that's all it is but people fall for
this stuff because he
sounds so confident when he says it
here's another whopper that we've dealt
with
before on immigration so you think that
most of the people that are progressive
that look at this
uh immigration issue and are more
liberal and more
they're more open to this idea of open
borders the reason why they're doing is
because they're kind of compassionate
but they haven't looked at the actual
statistics
of what this means and what happens and
why
and what's the incentive is that what
you believe that would be a kind way
a kind way what's the unkind way you
want more illegal immigration because
you want them to eventually become
citizens and vote for
you right so i think i think at the
higher ends of the
you know the democratic patriarchy so
joe rogan says
right like that makes obvious sense
democrats
want more immigrants because the
immigrants
will eventually become citizens vote for
democrats
and so democrats will win first of all
it's actually unclear whether more
immigrants becoming citizens
really means a a a substantively
impactful majority of democrats over
republicans
certainly latin american immigrants
other than cubans
and and even some venezuelans who in in
sort of like an anti-maduro
anti-castro reaction cubans and some
venezuelans tend to be
sort of more to the right other than
that latin american immigrants
certainly lean left but the cato think
cato institute which is a right wing
think tank researched this and they said
the question of whether immigrants are
really more left or more right
is a complicated question with lots of
moving parts
the point is even if immigrants skew
left
55 to 45 or even 60 40
that margin this is a really long play
this is a stupid way to try to win
elections because
for every 100 000 immigrants
who after five plus years remember
you come to the us with a green card
takes a while to get the green card
you need to be in the country five years
before you can apply for citizenship
getting citizenship can take one to two
more years that's like seven to eight
years
for what a 60 40 margin after seven
years
for every hundred thousand new citizens
if it's 60 40 you're only netting
20 000 voters right this is a very
stupid way to try to win elections and
it's sort of like when the right says oh
democrats are trying to win by having
people vote twice like drive to one
polling place and vote and then drive to
another polling place and vote under a
different name or whatever
do you understand how much work that is
to try to actually swing an election
and much the same way you know waiting
around seven years
for like what's maybe a 55 45 or 60 40
margin
on new citizens uh of that that are
naturalized
voting for it it's incredibly stupid so
you really have to be
political parties are barely able to
plan ahead two years
and dan crenshaw wants you to believe
that democrats on what is really
a a small margin of democrats over
republicans in terms of naturalized
citizens
are planning seven to eight years in
advance
as a strategy to win elections it
doesn't even pass the sniff test when
you think about it and again
unfortunately
because dan crenshaw says it so
confidently
people fall for it and if joe rogan is
going forward at least partially
you know that many in his audience are
so i could go on and on a dozen such
examples
dan crenshaw totally taking joe rogan
for a ride
with easily debunkable nonsense and
increasingly
dan crenshaw is becoming a hero of the
right wing it's sad
uh uh but but it's also dangerous
because
these bad ideas spread and they get
repeated with almost no critical
thinking applied to them whatsoever
let me know your thoughts in particular
if you saw this episode you can find me
on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
the david pakman show is an audience
supported
program i would love it if you added
your name to the hat
sign up for a membership at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code better21 for a
beautiful discount you will get access
to the daily bonus show
in audio and video formats as well as a
daily audio and video
commercial free stream of the daily
episodes sign up at joinpacman.com
i was browsing the david pakman show
subreddit this morning which is just a
few hundred subscribers from thirty
thousand you can join the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
the user blue falsata or falcata
uh sounding the alarm about what's going
on in brazil uh posting people in the
united states and the world
are sleeping on the humanitarian crisis
happening
in brazil right now only country in the
planet
hitting 3 000 daily deaths right now
it is almost something biblical as
sydney powell would say brazil has
elected
a true genocide as president i assume
they mean a genocidal maniac
uh it would take a long time to explain
the disaster but he is single-handedly
responsible for more than 300 000 deaths
he pushed hydroxychloroquine he doesn't
believe in vaccines rejected 70 million
doses for pfizer
uh yeah what's going on in brazil is is
absolutely tragic
brazil i believe they even had 4 000
deaths in a day
but you know what's really i mean as
it's a tragedy what's going on in brazil
but
brazil still has as of now
a lower per capita case rate than the
united states
overall for the pandemic and a lower per
capita
death rate than the united states when
you look at brazil and you see how
deaths are spiking and things are
completely out of control
we handled this so much worse than
brazil
for much of the pandemic during 2020
under donald trump's leadership or lack
thereof
that our numbers pandemic wide
are still worse than brazil's now
because we're vaccinating so much
and brazil is going in the wrong
direction it's quite plausible that in
four weeks or in six weeks brazil's
pandemic numbers overall will be worse
than ours
there's no question about that but it's
just incredible to think about that
things were just such a disaster in the
us for so long
that as bad as things are there we're
still worse off here
overall if you look at deaths and cases
per capita since the start of the
pandemic
another interesting post from user
hardin 1701
who says i watched david talk to that
trump apologist woman earlier
and i have no idea how he maintains his
composure while being confronted with
such supreme ignorance and
disinformation
attached is an economic study which
shows trump had
little positive effect on the economic
boom during his tenure
going on to say apart from her delusions
about how hands-on
and ceo like trump was she said one
thing that really pissed me off due to
her gross inhumanity she told david the
immigration problem is no longer mexican
and central americans entering looking
for jobs
she says the new challenge is
seven-year-olds making their way to the
border alone
or with the help of coyotes and being
dumped in the united states
her very next statement was if we don't
solve this problem it will have
consequences for working american jobs
does she mean from the seven-year-old
unaccompanied minors yeah
you know i got a bunch of emails from
the interview with republican strategist
amanda mackey earlier this week
and many of them pointed out david you
didn't push back on this you missed that
insane thing she said i know
she was gish galloping me and it's
difficult
to keep up you know you you have to pick
your battles
you have to pick your battles and so i
focused in on her claims about
trump being responsible for the vaccines
i focused in on her weird claims about
how trump's coveted bills were
bipartisan but
bidens weren't you have to pick your
battles and of course i missed things
and i will try to do better next time
but i'm glad that so many in the
audience noticed that there were way
more things she said that made no sense
than the ones that i was able to call
out join the discussion at the david
pakman show
subreddit davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t today
joe biden will be announcing multiple
executive actions on guns on
firearm safety it may already have
happened by the time you listened to
today's show or watch today's clips
this is already angering many people
but it has to happen because we have a
gun violence crisis in this country we
have a gun
culture crisis in this country one of
the actions joe biden is expected to
take is to deal with what are called
ghost
guns guns without serial numbers
sometimes which can be made at home
biden is expected to direct the
administration to start a process that
will require buyers
of so-called ghost guns to undergo
background checks a question remains
about
exactly what joe biden is going to do
and again but
by by now meaning when you're listening
to today's show we may already know
uh biden previously called on the senate
to pass
stricter background check rules the
house has already passed them
these would make background checks apply
to every gun sale and transfer
it would give the fbi more time to
conduct background checks
whether something related to that will
be part of the orders
we we just don't know yet uh joe biden
might announce some regulations
on concealed and or assault style
firearms maybe prohibitions on firearm
purchases for those
convicted of domestic violence against
partners
maybe something about alerting law
enforcement agencies when potential
buyers
fail background checks that these are
people you may want to keep an eye on as
they may try to obtain a firearm some
other way
potentially federal guidance on home
storage safety
measures there's a whole bunch of
possibilities and we'll know them very
soon if we don't already
but what we can be absolutely certain of
is that a huge portion of the american
right wing
will be against whatever joe biden
announces
they will say all the things that they
always say and to prepare you for that
we need to not lose sight of the big
picture whatever joe biden announces or
announced
today changes nothing about the second
amendment we have a second amendment
people have a right to own firearms none
of joe biden's orders will
change that joe biden essentially has no
choice
but to do this and why think back
to the sandy hook shooting when
democrats had
the white house under barack obama the
house of representatives
the senate and nearly 90 percent of
americans
supported a law for universal
background checks such a milk toast
thing such a basic thing
democrats still couldn't get it done
because of opposition
from republicans because of opposition
from the gun lobby
if you can't get universal background
checks done
in that environment after one of the
worst school shootings in american
history
controlling the white house house and
senate and having the american public on
your side
at an 88 to 90 percent level which is
almost unheard of
in the hyper partisan american political
status quo
i don't know that you can ever really
get anything done unless a president
just says
i'm doing executive action so this has
to happen
they will say biden is coming for your
guns they will say biden is ending the
second amendment none of it is true
but let's see what joe biden does
or did if it already happened depending
on when you listen to today's show
and then we will talk more about the
implications of what he does what he
does but
it has to be done there's no other
choice you know you hear from the right
some on the right say well we should
work together the the left the
democratic party shouldn't
uh act unilaterally what choice do they
have
when 90 of the country wants background
checks and republicans still don't
so once we know exactly what joe biden
signs we will
have more on this on the david pakman
show instagram page
make sure you are following us there at
david pakman show
on instagram the david pakman show
depends on the support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well
read about them every once in a while
probably every two months
we have a last-minute guest cancellation
sometimes they are the really
immoral no call no shows today our guest
actually is just feeling under the
weather so we're rescheduling them but
the upside
is i get to hear from some of you
instead
via the discord lines at davidpakman.com
slash
discord let's go today to ron
from south carolina ron what is going on
today
hello can you hear me yes i can
hey david i just wanted to um i've been
hearing a lot about the
about georgia passing voting uh changes
and i'm not really sure what's going on
with that um
how's that making voting harder because
i hear people say that a lot
okay yeah so georgia and a number of
other states so big picture
uh republicans didn't suppress enough of
the vote to win in november of 2020.
so uh very shortly after joe biden was
sworn in
something like 250 something
various bills across more than 40 states
were put in place
and many of these make it more difficult
to vote by putting in place stricter
voter id requirements
by limiting the number of places at
which people can vote by limiting voting
hours
and uh you can find you know the exact
details of every bill
uh online but that's the general idea
and these are often tailored
uh to none of these bills are ever
overtly written in a way that is
sort of classist or racist but as we've
talked about before
you can fine-tune and disproportionately
impact
certain groups you can target poorer
people for example
by making stricter id requirements where
to get the id the id itself is always
free
but to get the id you can put in place
more and more
requirements for what documents you need
to show some of the required documents
to get the id
aren't free and if you're poorer
you may even have to take a day off from
work in order to go
and pay for the document that you need
to get the id
and that's how you can for example
disproportionately impact
uh poor people i heard about and they're
also making
um making it illegal for people to hand
out water
in these really long lines yeah i i that
that
i did look at that i don't understand
the full
exactly how that's written that broke
while we were we were on break
but i don't know if that's uh in an
official capacity
you can't hand out water or or if just
nobody can give water to anybody else
that's in line but yeah i did read that
okay all right well thank you david all
right my pleasure thank you very much
uh let's go next uh to a tristan
from kansas city missouri tristan you're
on the air
hi uh david can you hear me yes i can
okay good
so i actually uh
i actually climbed up the pipeline
to uh deconvert myself from a stage of
conspiracism
so uh in 2016 i was basically q8 on
before qanon was a big thing
really like what were your beliefs well
i found some youtube conspiracy
theorists that basically said that obama
was going to declare martial law and all
that crap yeah
he was going to lock all the christians
in fema camps and they showed all this
quote unquote evidence that
you know that pizza parlor in washington
dc i i've found that before it was even
like
popular now let me ask you this this is
super interesting let's take one of
those which is
obama will lock up christians in fema
camps
when you fell for that did you
actually go through in your head like
okay what would be the authority
that comes up to do the locking up how
would they
identify who is christian like did you
did you think
in that level of detail well there was
there was a big theory that the whole
world was behind it it was like a secret
cabal and they have everybody's
information so you know based on your
internet history
if you're like a christian so they would
come and they would take away all the
people who
qualify under a specific criteria right
and it's a real mess my whole reason for
coming on here is
is to tell you that there are more
people like that than you think
you go to uh you know to find a radical
leftist it's really hard to find
you could probably find some at some
college campuses but i swear to god
these people these crazy cueing on
people they exist at every single dollar
store you go to in the right west
right and i i want to know david if you
how you handle all of this how you
handle all this insanity like does it
keep you up at night do you are you like
nervous for our future because the more
the further we get into this
and the further we get into seeing our
our climate getting destroyed and seeing
all this mis information come uh does it
ever scare you for the future knowing
that that more and more people are
losing their minds well listen
if you're paying attention and you're
not scared then you're not understanding
right but i do think that
you know applying stoic philosophy is
relevant
understand the limits of what you can
control
uh i can work to inform people about
what's going on with the climate but
ultimately i can't control the outcome
of whether we deal with climate so i
really do try to
remind myself that there's not much use
in worrying about things that are beyond
my control
i can certainly do my best to inform and
i can control that
but ultimately a lot of these issues are
bigger than any one person and and so i
think it's important to bear that in
mind
i take weekends off from the news and
from politics and i think that scheduled
breaks are also good but yeah if you're
paying attention
you you and you understand what's going
on of course you would be worried
okay thank you david that that pretty
much
i just wanted to know you know what was
going on behind the scenes now tristan
how what happened that you stopped
believing this crazy
conspiracy stuff what got you out of it
well well it's funny most people talk
about the alt-right pipeline how people
you know
climb down this rabbit hole to you know
find crazy ideologies for me i
it was it was conspiracism and then i
found
an episode of joe rogan talking alex
jones and that actually introduced me to
joe rogan i started watching him and
then he had on a few progressives
i watched tj kirk the amazing atheist
and he decom he you know he like
debunked a lot of these conspiracy
theories and then from there i found
secular talk and now
i'm listening to you and vosh and people
who would be considered more on the far
left end but i'm very skeptical with
that too i i try not to uh
fall down any more rabbit holes of
fringe
ideologies i try to keep it pretty
neutral most of the time well it seems
like you have a framework now
where anything you hear you will then
evaluate for yourself and and
research further rather than taking
anyone's word for anything which seems
cool of course
yeah of course i've learned my lessons
from that tristan congratulations
thank you david all right there we go
very very important stuff
extremely important stuff let's go next
to i think i'm pronouncing it correctly
is it aleyda or alida
yes it's a leader how are you elita
i'm good i can't believe i'm talking to
you i watch you every day
thank you uh my question to you
um is in regards to the voter
suppression bill in georgia
yes of course there's been something
like 253
other legislations going to all 50
states yep
is there something if they don't get it
resolved is there something that joe
biden
joe body can do to override these voter
suppression laws
i don't know that there's anything biden
can do
but there is much that the house and
senate can do and there's currently a
bill
that would enshrine certain voter
enfranchisement voting rights
protections it's unclear
uh whether that's going to pass i think
that this is this is
not something biden can do directly but
it's certainly something the house and
senate can do
um in a way that would create a
framework that
all states have to meet certain
guidelines and states wouldn't be able
to
uh go beyond or or ignore some of these
federal election guidelines so that
would be that's the path forward i think
okay in order to do that they would have
to get rid of the filibuster
you think that's a good question i mean
listen um
i think they're i don't know the answer
i i i would like to think there's a way
to get it through the senate without
blowing up the filibuster but yeah i
mean
you're you're definitely on to something
it's conceivable that the filibuster
would need to be done away with to pass
that yeah that that's
that's quite a possibility okay
well thank you so much david my pleasure
elita great to speak to you
good good to speak to you too have a
good day you too elita
perfect phone call i would say um why
don't we go next to
trent from miami trent from miami you
were on the air
yes hi david can you hear me yes i can
awesome
uh i have a question about um
the border wall uh and uh
the possibility of uh
of of biden uh restarting it
and uh there was that that was a rumor
that i think was flowing around
yesterday and representative ilhan
omar said it would be really bad for joe
biden to
uh continue building trump's racist
border wall and i had a discussion with
my best friend
about uh whether trump's border wall
comes from a racist place or not and i
was more leaning on the side that
uh that the wall since it was um
being pushed by uh certain right-wing
pundits
and uh trump and steve bannon behind the
scenes that uh
you were kind of leaning into this uh
racially
tinged socioeconomic populist rhetoric
that because of that
the wall uh is inherently
racist but my my best friend wasn't
seeing it that way it was
he saw it more as well we need border
security
and uh and we need to solve our illegal
immigration problems so i don't really
see
the where the racism comes in that's
what my best friend said
so um i was just i wanted to ask uh
what because it's it's you know these
past four years have kind of all blurred
together
you know uh with everything that the
former president has done
i got yeah so the question is whether
whether i think it's racist so listen
please do what you can to silence your
discord the blings are just
unbearable that's in the call-in guide
so please check that out if you're
unsure how to do that
here's the thing i to say whether a
a wall in a wall itself is just a wall
so i don't know that we can say that a
wall is racist i think the question is
whether the intentions of those
looking to put up a wall are racist
and to be perfectly frank i think it
doesn't matter i don't even engage with
that issue
because the point is the wall doesn't
really achieve
what we what we claim to want to achieve
it doesn't really fix the issue of
undocumented immigration
um only a third of undocumented
immigrants are physically crossing the
u.s mexico border two-thirds are
overstaying visas just flying in for a
trip and never going home
etcetera the wall can be defeated as
we've seen with like 150 dollars in
parts from your average
hardware store and the wall doesn't deal
with
the economic situation in the countries
from which people are coming and a
far better investment would be to deal
with that by working with those
countries
so you know a wall is a wall the reasons
for building it can be racist
some of the people who want the wall are
racist some maybe not
but i i don't know that it really
matters too much because there's
other bigger issues with the wall and
with immigration policy that i would
focus on
great thank you david all right i'm
gonna let you go thank you yeah
instructions uh on how to silence those
discord blings because those
people get very upset i get a lot of
emails saying david i can't listen to
the calls when they're blinging and
blinging and blinging
let's go next to chris from san antonio
you were on the air
chris from san antonio hey david can you
help me yes i can
hey how it's going doing well good good
so i've been listening to your show a
long time appreciate it to be on um
i guess i'd consider myself progressive
but i do take some issues i guess
with some of just the the thought
pattern
that some progressives have um like in
terms of like
just for example like medicare for all
like i do think that's a good idea and i
do support that
but i don't think it's like the um you
know it's going to fix all the problems
i guess i would say
you know the health care system in the
country it's it's really health
insurance
it means medicare for all and um
you know coming from a medical
background um
you know 80 to 90 percent of the
diseases in the country
are preventable it's you know mostly
related to diet and things like that is
it that high i mean i know it's
significant but i've never heard 80 to
90
um that's the figure i've heard i mean
it's really looking at diabetes
hypertension
heart disease those those type of things
where yeah
you know the american diet is just so
bad yep
that it's really causing a lot of those
problems and unfortunately you know
if we have medicare for all i just feel
like it's going to exacerbate
you know people's bad you know health
decisions so i don't i don't think
medicare for all will
exacerbate people's bad health decisions
i do agree with you
that medicare for all is neither a
panacea nor the only way to go about
getting people universal coverage
i think it's one way to do it i think
there's other countries that have other
systems that work
quite well and what i tell people is i
don't
for me this isn't partisan in any way i
just want the best solution
and one of the best books i think to
read about how
medicare for all is one option but there
are others that around the world work
as well uve reinhardt's
last book which i think was actually
published posthumously by
by his widow is one of the best books
for explaining
the balance that any healthcare system
has to find on a triangle between
access quality and cost every system is
just
picking a point on a triangle between
those three
uh axes so to speak and um
there's nothing magical about medicare
for all and in that sense i i agree with
you it's one way to go about it
yeah what i would you know what what i
would love to see more focus on
is preventative care in the country of
course so like just for example
you know why couldn't there be you know
food stamps for all
that can only be used for you know the
most scientifically proven
healthy foods in the country yeah that
that's not the way i would go no that
was so that the problem is when we start
saying
because then you get into food stamps
can't be used
for ketchup because it's processed i
think that that's
that's very that's micro i think we need
a macro strategy of like
for example shifting to where
health providers are paid for keeping
people healthy
rather than being paid for the number of
things they do to a patient
that's like a macro change it's less
about controlling what food stamps can
be used for i disagree with you there
respectfully of course
no yeah i understand that yeah it's you
know obviously
the politicians are you know they are
going to be responsible for the people
and the
people just say no i want to eat this
you know right it's not going to go well
for them so
i mean i understand that but i do wish
also progressives would
focus a little bit more on the meat
dairy egg industry because i do think it
it really um correlates to a lot of
things progressive care about you know
the environment
um health care uh you know just
uh living conditions you know both for
you know the people
you know that are there working in those
fields as well as you know the animals
are just
you know that's just all swept under the
rug and you know
the average person really doesn't you
know understand where their food comes
from
so yeah certainly progressives would
take that that battle but yeah
i would encourage people to read um
michael pollan's uh
books on on the food industry and and
these things
and you know it things keep pointing to
uh eating uh not eating factory foods
buying ingredients rather than food
products
and uh having a modest amount of uh
of of certain types of meats in your
diet you know we
over time all these diets come in and
out of of favor
but really we just continue getting more
and more evidence of the things we
suspected 20 30 years ago
right yeah yep and i would the final
point i would
love to see is you know smoking really
dropped down once you know the
warnings were put on the packages um you
know i think that's that's a route that
could go with
meat products you know considering they
are considered class one car
carcinogens so you know yeah i don't
know about that i know that um
i know that i know that bacon has been
uh definitively shown
uh if i recall correctly to uh
maybe be carcinogenic i want to make
sure i'm being careful in what i say
but some of the healthiest diets around
the world uh
contain you know modest amounts modest
amounts of meat so i think we want to be
careful about you know these these
broad state sweeping statements right
yeah i think there was a 2015 the world
health organization did classify
any deli meat so that includes hot dogs
any sliced meats
class 1 carcinogens 1a or something like
that so it's like the same category as
smoking and
i would stay away from the processed
meats absolutely absolutely
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call chris from san antonio glad
to have been able to
speak to a few folks today our guest
canceled that's not good
but then i got to speak to a few of you
which is great we're going to take a
break and we will be back with more
right after this
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what
pat does all day very very concerning to
a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account
at david pakman show so as we talked
about earlier this week
those who are still republicans
overwhelmingly still support former
president donald trump the numbers
of thinking back to the monday show
something like 80 percent of republican
voters still view donald trump favorably
something like 70 percent of republican
voters want donald trump to run for
president
in 2024 that's not the problem
increasingly the problem for the
republican party is that there are fewer
and fewer
republicans left and what i mean by that
is that the number of americans who
identify as republicans or as
independents leaning republican is
down to just 40 percent as of the first
quarter of 2021. now on the other hand
the number of democrats and democratic
leading independents
is up to 49 that's a nine-point gap
49 to 40 for democrats and democratic
leading independents over republicans
and republican-leaning independents
this is now the biggest democratic
advantage
that gallup has measured dating back
almost a decade to the fourth quarter of
2012
when barack obama was re-elected and
this
is something that gallup measures
regularly and what gallup has found
is that there are some very specific
reasons why
so many voters have abandoned the
republican party
i don't think any of these are
particularly surprising number one
joe biden winning the 2020 presidential
election
and being inaugurated just after the
humiliating
and disastrous january 6th trump riots
has pushed millions of people away from
the republican party
and either towards being independents or
towards the democratic party
the expansion of coronavirus vaccination
has helped move people away from the
republican party
the passage of joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar
coveted stimulus package has moved
people away from the democratic i'm
sorry away from the republican party
towards the democratic party now to be
very clear
this is not the biggest gap we've ever
seen between republican and democratic
registration
if you go back to sort of the 2006 to
2009
era democrats actually had a
double-digit advantage in registration
there
if you go back further almost uh what
would it be almost 30 years ago
in 1992 around the time of the election
of president bill clinton
democrats also had a double-digit
advantage
at that point in time so this is
obviously very
bad news for republicans in theory if it
translates
into how people vote in 2022 and 2024
but we should temper our expectations
and there's a few things to keep in mind
here
uh first of all in a country where often
half the country doesn't vote or you
know if turnout is really high
35 of the country still doesn't vote
having a nine point a ten point a twelve
point party registration
uh advantage doesn't necessarily win you
elections if you're looking at it from
the republican perspective
having a nine-point party registration
deficit doesn't have to lose you
elections
uh depending on who actually goes out to
vote but we can actually control that
with turnout if we get out the vote then
we can turn that
a party registration advantage into a
real world benefit there's a bigger
problem we can't control
which is that within states you have
such outrageous
partisan gerrymandering right now that
was done by the republican party
where just to win half of house seats
democrats need
significantly more than half the votes
uh and
that is also a real problem for the
democratic party but probably
the most important takeaway here
is we've been saying that republicans
have launched more than 250
voter suppression bills across more than
40 states
because too many people voted in 2020.
the results in 2020 were proof to
republicans we didn't do enough voter
suppression we need to suppress
more vote and that's why they are now
filing
and pushing more than 250 voter
suppression bills there's another aspect
of this
this party registration data republicans
seeing
we are hemorrhaging voters we are seeing
attrition
of republican voter registration that
also is making them realize we have to
suppress more votes we have to pass some
of these 250 bills
the republican party believes that when
they are winning
it's a free country and they're winning
because they're winning the battle of
ideas
but when they're not winning this is a
socialist
tyrannical authoritarian nightmare
executed by
communists such as joe biden and they
will do anything they can
on that basis to win elections now one
one last thought here
just because there are fewer republicans
gerrymandering aside voter turnout aside
just because there are fewer republicans
doesn't necessarily mean that a lot of
those former republicans
are going to go out and vote for
democrats they may not vote at all
they may no longer be republicans but
they will still vote for republicans
when they see who it is that's on the
ballot
unless you can turn this registration
deficit or margin depending on which
side you're looking at it from
into election victories into political
victories
they are merely interesting numbers now
the question is whether democrats can
actually do anything with it
i'd want to get you caught up on
something
we talked about at the start of the week
fox news
comedy show and i'm using that term
very loosely fox news comedy show
gutfeld debuted on monday night and it's
maybe the least funny comedy show that
i've ever seen
and one of the questions i asked on
monday was why does right
wing comedy not work many of you weighed
in
and i'm going to have some of your
thoughts in a couple of minutes
somehow in the first week the show has
gotten
even less funny check out a couple of
these clips from last night's episode
here's i th these terms
it's they're of questionable meaning
here is a sketch
or a skit about how if the master's golf
tournament
is racist then anything with the word
master is therefore racist take a look
somehow this voter id law was racist
meanwhile
they still have the masters right yeah
it's called the masters
if master bedrooms are racist the
masters are racist
masturbation is racist master chef
is racist what is masturbation no i
don't know is your dad watching oh your
dad's in the audience
very good joe i am dying to find out
what's in your brain
who thinks that's funny the only funny
thing about it
is i can't really i can't think of
anything that's really funny about
it now one of the big controversies
around the masters has actually been
that augusta national golf club
doesn't allow women and then that's
getting mixed up with the georgia voter
law stuff
uh which are you know racially
suppressive uh
along along racial lines the jokes don't
even make sense never mind being funny
for the third night in a row they did
another segment about cnn
supposedly being obsessed with racism
three nights running the exact same
joke even though i don't even know what
the joke is vacation
isn't the goal conflict is and once you
see this framework it shows up
everywhere
i mean take a look at what's on cnn
right now
grandma's narcissist butterscotch racism
you don't call your grandmother all
right
maybe the bear does have a point there
the bear is a racist
he is a racist so three nights in a row
with that one i don't know if they can't
come
come up with anything better or they
think that that one's really working
it's not clear
if it was a good joke i could maybe see
going with it like go with what works
this is not a joke that's working and i
also am wondering like is there really a
studio audience or is the laughter just
employees who are hanging out in the
room because it sounds
very very sparse like it's all very
strange every detail
if you were to if you were trying to
make a satire
of right wingers doing a comedy show
this is what
a saturday night live skit about right
wing comedy shows would look like
but this is actually the show so now on
to your comments
i asked on monday why can't right
wingers do comedy
why doesn't it work and i got a bunch of
interesting responses
many of you wrote to me and said you
know david the the reason right
you said sir the reason right wing
comedy doesn't work
is because right wingers want to watch
news channels
and get angry not watch news channels
and laugh i think there's probably
something to that to some degree
another idea is that right wingers
become motivated and
activated by disinformation that's
presented as fact
so when they have disinformation
presented as comedy
they're not sure like are we supposed to
laugh are we supposed to take it
seriously are we supposed to rant in all
caps on twitter like what are we
supposed to do
as a result of this a bunch of people
made some pretty aggressive comments
about intelligence
saying you know if you're dumb enough to
fall for what fox news reports as news
you probably don't have the intelligence
to understand comedy or satire or parody
and it's the wrong audience in other
words the idea that an appreciation of
humor requires a level of intelligence
that your average fox news viewer lacks
that's a very aggressive statement for
sure uh but maybe there's something to
it you tell me
one person wrote in and said the problem
is that the jokes are both
lazy but too mean-spirited
they you really need them to be clever
and slightly mean-spirited like they're
not calibrated correctly
one viewer suggested that the problem is
that it is
humor but it's basically an adult
version
of the high school bullies making fun of
the one disabled kid or the one black
kid
so it just comes off as like crass and
inappropriate rather than funny
that's a pretty interesting analogy
actually there may be something to that
and then last thing and there's a common
thread to all of these
someone wrote to me and suggested
they're not really doing satire
they're expressing their the same
contempt that they express
all the time in a way that they hope
will get people to laugh
and it just doesn't work i think there's
something to all of these critiques
for sure let me know why you think
this right-wing comedy idea is not
working let me know how long you think
this show will last as i told you on
monday the half hour news hour which was
the last attempt at comedy by fox news
i it lasted 17 episodes i don't remember
if that was a weekly show or a daily
show
17 episodes on a weekly show is 17 weeks
17 episodes on a weeknight show is like
three and a half weeks
i don't know but tell me how long you
think the gutfeld show looks like it's
going to last
we have a voicemail number which is
2192davidp
at the top of the show today we covered
the dan crenshaw interview with joe
rogan
i got tons of messages and and
voicemails about it
here's one that's asking about sort of
like what's going on with dan crenshaw
take a listen
hey david did you happen to catch dan
crenshaw on joe rogan
last week is he just stupid or is he
just pulling this
to uh continue the tired conservative
logic on how
taxes and society should work i think
he's just as dumb as madison cothorn and
lauren bobert and the like where are all
the intellectual conservatives in the
government
so my i addressed this a little bit in
the first segment i think
that dan crenshaw knows he's bs'ing
i don't from everything i know about dan
crenshaw
uh he's smart enough and informed enough
to know
that the things he said to joe rogan a
couple of days ago
and the things he said on fox news last
night about what is fascism and
medicaid and you know immigration
i think he knows that it's bs but he bel
he correctly believes the average
trumpist will believe it
if your position is that no dan crenshaw
really is ignorant
uh let me know but my best assessment
right now
and it can be difficult to tell
sometimes is that crenshaw
is gaslighting not crenshaw is stupid
we have a bonus show today on which we
will be discussing
the push for a fourth
coronavirus stimulus check there is a
push for this we will talk about it
we will also talk about a utah law that
requires
biological fathers to pay half of
pregnancy-related medical costs period
regardless of
anything else and lastly jeff bezos
has come out in support of a higher
corporate tax rate which joe biden is
now pushing
my question is if you deduct
your taxable income down to zero does it
matter what the corporate tax rate is in
other words
if amazon is paying 21 of zero
or 28 of zero or 35 percent of zero why
the hell does amazon care what the
corporate tax rate is i think that
there's a uh
propagandistic element to this which we
will talk about on today's bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show
simply by signing up
at joinpakman.com i'll see you then